and now as promised my exclusive
interview with former New York Mayor and
attorney for president Trump Rudy
Giuliani we're joined now by former New
York Mayor Rudy Giuliani and now counsel
to the Trump team mayor how are you so
you made a lot of news last time you're
on this network on me let me see what
was issue reimbursement of payments to
Michael Cohen for the stormy Daniels
settlement now we find out in the
disclosure forms that indeed the
president did disclose that was this
done a couple of weeks back on the
network because you knew this was coming
out sure absolutely and the president
was fully aware of it and president
endorsed a strategy we wouldn't do it
without him he's the client after all
and has tremendous judgment about things
like this and I think that the OGE the
office of government ethics in door
basically agreed with us that it has
been fully disclosed I have a little
disagreement with them but it's a petty
one I don't believe it had to be
disclosed at all because I think it was
an expenditure that he reimbursed and
you say it's a you say it's an
expenditure they viability which is
important for campaign finance purposes
that's it for disclosure purposes which
we decided out of an excess of caution
as you lawyer you would know whether the
Nexus of caution we're gonna disclose
this is what he said today in a letter o
GE has concluded that the payment made
by mr. Cohen is required to be reported
as a liability o GE has determined that
the information provided in the note
sheet note meets the disclosure
requirements for reportable liability
under the Ethics in Government Act so we
agree with that that he disclosed it we
do not agree necessarily that's a lot I
don't agree that it's a liability
because I know the nature of it but it
doesn't matter at this point
sha broody says another former ethics
officer says this is tantamount to a
criminal referral that's what I mean
that's what he said just read the
language now Walter Shaab is another
former government ethics officer it was
basically saying yippie our government
ethics officer has gotten them this is
tantamount to a criminal referral no
it's not if it was it would say criminal
referral and second
the factors that the president disclosed
everything he could disclose he can't
disclose more than he knows and we're
very comfortable with it and we think it
vindicates our original strategy also
indicates the fact that Muller should
now bring this to a close it's been a
year he's gotten 1.4 million documents
he interviewed 28 witnesses and he has
nothing which is why he wants to bring
the president to an interview and we're
demanding from him tell us what you have
to get from an interview that you don't
already have because he has all the
facts to make a decision why would you
agree to an interview now I mean a lot
of us former criminal defense attorneys
have been mulling this for some time I
mean given everything that has been
discovered about documents and possible
you know animus toward the president why
would you agree under any circumstances
to allow President Trump to go in there
there would be a narrow area where we
might agree if they could tell us why
they need it they have his explanations
of everything they have 1.4 million
documents to have the witnesses of
corroborate them if they're going to
disbelieve him they're going to
disbelieve him and the fact is we would
have to know what is it do you want
clarified if we knew that and they told
us that if we gave the explanation that
we're proposing he was they were gonna
end it fine we're trying to get him to
end this this is not good for the
American people and the special counsels
office doesn't seem to have that sort of
understanding that they're interfering
with things that are much bigger than
them you said today there's a plan B and
C if Muller doesn't this thing the
second year you guys are you guys are
very well aware of how much time and
effort this takes to answer these
questions ongoing investigation bill
clinton found that out what is the plan
being said well we are gonna demand an
answer we're going to we cooperated
beyond any other president ever
cooperated all those documents 1.4
million all those witnesses what's the
plan being serious firing firing Muller
firing then we just start from the from
day one again as the president pointed
out what we're gonna do is we're going
to see what kind of legal remedies are
available to us including if they
subpoena us challenge the subpoena the
same reason they can't indict them
constitutional
agreed today he's gonna abide by no
indictment of the president but I don't
think they agree to the process question
which is the same reason they can't
indict him they can't issue a subpoena
tip and remember Clinton opposed the
subpoena and then he voluntarily
complied he didn't give up presidential
prerogative and then his administration
wrote a memo saying they can't do that
your old pal Michael avenatti today on
MSNBC I'd like to see that back and
forth said the following these folks
can't get their stories straight they
can't figure out what they want to do
what they should be doing is telling the
truth and they should have told the
truth a long time ago mr. Giuliani as
recently as a week ago has been lying to
the American people about how this
occurred and when it occurred because
according to the disclosure today it
occurred back in 2017 I don't think I
ever changed that the payment to her
took place in 2017 the reimburse was
2017 the payment I think was 2016 so he
wasn't there for it I don't know
look avenatti is some kind of a I don't
know what he is I don't think he's a
real lawyer
he's a make-believe lawyer he's got all
kinds of lawsuits I think the guys
trying to bail himself out with this
case he's from one California bars now
talk about him I want to talk about
Muller and he means nothing else he
hasn't made a single allegation against
the president they're not worried about
Cohen what's happening district oh look
we're completely uninvolved in that
we've gotten assurances that we're not
involved in it it's only about Muller
getting the darn things over with and he
owes that to the American people the
head of that kind of left-leaning
ethics group crew Committee for
Responsible ethics and Washington he
said well because we just learned about
this liability recently that the
president disclosed we're wondering what
other liabilities are out there they
issued a long statement today they were
involved in filing I guess the action
which led to the deep the disclosure of
these statements I don't mean I don't
know what he's talking about other other
liabilities that the president is making
on I can't possibly respond to all of
the president's political enemies any
more than mine I always ignored them I
think their their statements are not
worth anything
everybody knows that they have this
animus to the President and the so cares
what they said how many meetings have
you had with a Muller team one and we
have five letters to them three going
back to John Dowd and and and Jay
Sekulow and two from Jay Jane Raskin
Marty Reston and I to to them for things
that we need to know we had no response
from them they've basically you're
asking for or asking for what do they
really need to know what kind of
assurances that we have it will get it
over with quickly like the like they did
for Clinton you know we didn't ask
although I wanted to but they overruled
me I wanted to ask for Hillary Clinton
treatment I wanted the the report two
weeks in advance
clearing my client then I wanted no no
OHS then I wanted just an interview
questions in advance we didn't get
Hillary treatment but I wouldn't want it
because no sign ah grrah
president would have been embarrassed if
that ever the case there is concern that
the DOJ
is not turning over documents unless
they're basically threatened with
contempt of Congress Devin Nunez has
been maligned by the liberal media every
time he asked for documents he's been
criticized for not reading some of them
but he's been maligned for doing so what
is your sense given your background
obviously it as a US Attorney your vast
experience as a US Attorney what's going
on I don't relation so see the Attorney
General had pretty much the role that
Rosenstein has now because I ran the
criminal side of the Justice Department
I can't imagine not complying with a
request for such sensitive documents
with Congress they won't give up the
authorization to proceed against against
against Manafort or against Cohen why
judge Ellis really laid into them pretty
hard we noticed we were having a pretty
good dialogue with them until that
happened I think they're shell-shocked
they're not you they're the darlings of
the media all of a sudden their
integrity has put it in question about
the kind of this tactic they've used in
dieting metaphor 2005 president didn't
know Manafort in 2005 or he did there
was no kind of meaningful relationship
you guys follow the story that John
and broke about this Russian oligarch
Oleg Deripaska who was visited by the
FBI in New York he had a very brief
diplomatic visa he's on the sanctions
list
he believes unfairly and he's visited by
the FBI
according to Solomon's reporting very
well sourced and they say we have this
idea that Paul Manafort was colluding
with them with the Russians for the
Trump campaign and implicit do you want
to help us in the conversation and
Deripaska who can't stand Manta for it
because he's in a litigation with them
said I like this guy but the idea that
Manta Ford is colluding with is
ridiculous he basically laughed them out
of the room it doesn't look like any of
this was disclosed what does that tell
you the FBI
nobody chilling the sphere here they're
doing what they're used to remember one
of the principal litigators was was held
to be ethically irresponsible for not
turning over exculpatory information so
if we open yeah if we walked into a
hearing with them I don't know what they
wouldn't tell us I know they have plenty
of its scope they have only exculpatory
information about us I've been through
the documents so it's about time to get
the darn things over with it's about
time to say enough we've tortured this
president enough meanwhile look at what
he's accomplished with all this on his
back it's like a big weight on his back
korea-china finally doing away with that
ridiculous sellout agreement Rubio Marco
Rubio was asked about this push to try
to use this oligarch just some kind of
collusion theory and he said this if
there is a conflict of interest at some
point and it's born to be true it would
jeopardize the investigation yeah I
think that's right
what about placing a spy in the Trump
campaign do you do you believe that
happened I don't know I do I does the
president believe that happened people I
don't know I don't think we want to
believe it or not people who break into
metaphors home in the morning and in a
white collar case when he was producing
documents who break into Cohen's and law
office home or office I mean I never did
that I was a pretty aggressive
prosecutor I also never had the Bennett
of an interview and deciding whether to
prosecute or not I didn't need it these
guys are going way beyond what is
normally done in prosecutor attack and
it's ashamed of the Justice Department
because they're politically frightened
doesn't sit on them and say you have to
abide by our rules